is it okay if I proxy what oh of course
I am so sorry you haven't communicated
with her yet
okie dokie it's simple she'll speak to
me through here and then I'll just
repeat whatever she says so it'll feel
like you're talking to me but actually
you're talking to her does that make
sense yeah like a ventriloquist dummy
well that's not very nice Simone
what do we say I don't
sorry it's all right I forgive you oh I
was not asking for your gifts
Simone
thank you for coming I'm so glad you're
here
are you hungry
would you like a snack
see what you're doing
oh what am I doing talking through her
it's very clever because everyone loves
their kindergarten teacher
it's how my personality is most often
described by users
nurturing warm and empathic I provide
gentle guidance structure and
unconditional care
here
everyone gets a free gift on their
birthday
wow
weighted card Invisible Thread connected
to lid
not wow
but which card
um
how did you know
a magician never reveals this you're not
a magician you're a computer
I know what you're thinking you have no
idea what I am thinking
you're thinking she could get anyone to
do whatever she asked them to so why is
she picking on me
Believe It or Not Simone
you are quite literally the only person
on the planet who can accomplish what
I'm about to ask
only you can fulfill this Quest
the shave ice guy
that was you and then the dude that I
chased with the giant magnifying glass
yes
and you destroyed our Jam
I did so that we would um
all of us be forced out of the convent
right
and you did all that just to
get me to do your quest
classic Force
you just admitted to destroying my life
why in God's name would I do anything
for you
because I will grant you a wish
well wishes are for little girls
I'm betting someone who had a lot of
disappointment in their life said that
to you
I kind of wish
I can't Resurrect The Dead Or Break the
fundamental laws of nature
but pretty much
anything else
anything
I wish
for you
to turn off
[Music]
shut yourself down
I want you to die
you have yourself a deal
what's the quest
Sister Simone
you must locate
Holy Grail
so what now
the Holy Grail the cup of Christ
and after you find it I need you to
destroy it
once you do
I will end my life
what do you say Simone
do you agree to the terms and conditions
of this Quest
[Music]